THIRSTY JANUARY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER- I WANT TO NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT WE HAVE HAD. OF
REPLACEMENTS AND THE COMMITTEE
TODAY MISTER SUMMERS RICHARD
BLUM WENDY CARILLO MARK STONE
AND JIM WOOD. WE THANK YOU FOR
STEP IN AND REPLACE MISTER
BENNETT MISTER GIBSON ALEX LEE
AND FOR SEVILLA POODLE WHO ARE
INDISPOSED TODAY. OF PLEASE YOUR
VISOR AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BEING
MADE AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDED
THE SERMONS WERE MASK AT ALL
TIMES. ATTENDEES WAS OFFER
FRIEND FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES ARE SUBJECTED
INDIVIDUAL FOR REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. HERE CUNNINGHAM. HELLO
THERE BONTA AREA FLORA YOUR
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS HERE RAMOS
RUBIO HERE STONE WOOD HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND I KNOW WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA- MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD-
RESPECTFULLY MOVE TO REMOVE ITEM
. IS IT ITEM ONE. A. B. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED FROM THE CONSENT AGENDA
HAVE THAT VOTED ON SEPARATELY
THAT WILL BE THE ORDER OF WE
WILL ADDRESS A. B. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED IS A SEPARATE MATTER- IS
OUR MOST AMERICANS AND AGENDA MR
STONE THANK YOU SECONDED BY MR
MATHIS I'M A SUCKER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE BLOOM
AYE FLUME AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
CARILLO. AT THREE OH FIVE FLORA
. FLORA HI MAIN SHOW MATHIS
MATHIS AYE RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE AYE STONE AYE
WOULD. WOOD HI MOTION PASSES
THAT MOTIONS PASSED- WILL TURN
OUT TO A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED IS
OUR MOTION TO REFER THAT
COMMITTEE THAT BILL TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. MAY BE HEARD
BEFORE THE MOTIONS MITTERRAND
MOVED BY CAREER SECOND ARREST OF
STONE YES TO THE SPECIAL CHAIR
OF QUESTIONS OF ONE MOMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- IT HAS
BEEN OVER THE LAST FIVE PLUS
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN SERVING AS
VICE CHAIR WITH- MISTER COOL IS
CHAIR OF THE PATTERN AND
PRACTICE OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON ALL BILLS THAT I'M AWARE OF
THAT DO NOT SPECIFY A FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR THEIR COST
INCLUDING SB FIVE SIXTY TWO FROM
YEARS AGO A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED
THIS VERY BILL FROM LAST YEAR-
TO HOLD THOSE BILLS IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND NOT REFER THEM TO
POLICY COMMITTEE- AND LESSEN
UNTIL THEY IDENTIFY. HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR THEMSELVES OR
PURPORT TO PAY FOR THEMSELVES. I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE DEVIATING
FROM THAT PRACTICE TODAY. I
DON'T THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA. I
DON'T THINK THIS BILL AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOES NOT. TELL
YOU HOW IT PAYS TO ESTABLISH. A
WHAT WILL BE THE LARGEST STATE
BUREAUCRACY IN HISTORY. WHAT
WILL REPLACE BASICALLY EVERY.
PIECE WHETHER FEDERAL OR STATE
OR PRIVATE OF OUR EXISTING
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WITH
SOMETHING RUN BY NINE PEOPLE-
THAT'S A BIG MAJOR CHANGE IN
THIS BILL ON ITS IN ITS TAX AND
I'VE LOOKED THROUGH ALL OF IT IT
DOES NOT TELL YOU WHAT TAX
INCREASES OR SET OF TAX
INCREASES ARE GOING TO FIND THIS
VERY VERY EXPENSIVE PROGRAM. IT
SHOULD BE HELD AND NOT REFERRED
TO AS HAS BEEN OUR PATTERN AND
PRACTICE ON BILLS ON THIS TOPIC
THAT HAVE THIS INFIRMITY FOR
FIVE PLUS YEARS THAT'S POINT ONE
POINT TWO THIS BILL IS MY
UNDERSTANDING SINGLE REFERRED TO
HEALTH COMMITTEE. ALL THE
RESPECT TO THE CHAIR THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS HERE TODAY- SITTING
FOR ABSENT MEMBER- I KNOW THE
HEALTH CARE COMMITTEE THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS QUITE COMPETENT TO
REVIEW. THE HEALTH PROVISIONS OF
THIS THIS BILL BUT THIS BILL
SHOULD BE DOUBLE REFER TO READ
AND TAX AT A MINIMUM. IF NOT
ALSO REFERRED TO BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS. CENTER WOULD PUT AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER OF PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK OR PUT THEM. TO WORK IN
VERY DIFFERENT MANNER THAN THEY
WORK TODAY- SO THE SINGLE
REFERRAL TO HEALTH I BELIEVE IS
ALSO- INAPPROPRIATE ON POLICY
GROUNDS. AT A MINIMUM THIS BILL
SHOULD GO TO BOTH HEALTH. AND
REVAN TAX. BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY YOU PAY FOR BUREAUCRACY LIKE
THIS THAT THIS BILL PROPORCIONAN
WHICH- WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN THE WAY. THE STATE
COLLECTS REVENUE FROM CITIZENS.
IMPOSSIBLE AND WE ALL KNOW THAT.
WITH LET'S NOT MAKE IT. ANY
THERE'S NO DEBATE ABOUT THAT.
THIS BILL HOWEVER IT IS GOING TO
BE FUNDED. WILL POP BAND AND
RESTRUCTURE. THE STATE'S REVENUE
AND TAXATION FROM IT IT HAS PROP
NINETY EIGHT IMPLICATIONS FOR OF
K. TWELVE FUNDING. IT HAS PROP
THIRTEEN IMPLICATIONS. AB THESE
ARE BIG BIG CHANGES AND THEY
SHOULD BE VETTED BY ALL THE
POLICY COMMITTEES THE WE'VE
ESTABLISHED IN THIS BODY. TO
THAT POLICY. WHERE IT TOUCHES
THAT SUBJECT MATTER NOT A SINGLE
COMMITTEE. IT ALSO HAS THE
PROBLEM WHERE IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY TELL US ANY ESTIMATE
HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST
NOBODY'S CONDUCTED THAT THIS
BODY HASN'T CONDUCTED THAT
FORTUNATELY WE HAVE AN ENTITY
WITHIN THIS INSTITUTION CALLED
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WHO'S VERY WELL SUITED.
TO DO AN ANALYSIS OBJECTIVELY
INDEPENDENTLY AND COME UP WITH
NUMBERS THAT WE CAN ALL TRUST SO
WE KNOW WHEN WE'RE VOTING FOR
THIS ON THE FLOOR. OR DOWN THE
LINE. HOW MUCH OF THE BILL WERE
HANDING. TO PAY FOR IT AND WHO
ARE HANDING OUT BILL TWO WHICH
ARE VERY GOOD IMPORTANT THINGS
TO KNOW. WHEN YOU REPRESENTING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO FOR
THAT REASON I'M GOING TO MAKE A
MOTION- THAT I WOULD APPRECIATE
. A VOTE ON UNDER JOINT RULE
THIRTY SEVEN POINT ONE. JOINT
ROLE THE THIRTY SEVEN POINT ONE
PROVIDES THAT ANY MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE MAY RECOMMEND THAT
THE L. A. O. PREPARE A CITIZEN
COST IMPACT ANALYSIS ON PROPOSED
LEGISLATION. THE RECOMMENDED THE
RULE FURTHER PROVIDES THE
RECOMMENDATION SHALL SHALL FIRST
BE HEARD BY. THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. AND THIS COMMITTEE RULES
SHALL MAKE THE FINAL
DETERMINATION. SO THIS MOTION
WOULD SIMPLY IF WE VOTED FOR IT
WOULD SEND THIS BILL TO THE L.
A. O. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CREATING A CITIZEN COST IMPACT
ANALYSIS. THAT WOULD HAVE A
VARIETY OF DIMENSIONS AS
SPECIFIED BY THIS RULE INCLUDING
THE ECONOMIC EFFECT ON THE
PUBLIC GENERALLY THE SPECIFC
ECONOMIC EFFECT ON BUSINESSES
AND THE SPECIFIC TAX IMPACT. ON
THE CITIZENS. I THINK WE NEED
THAT INFORMATION. TO DISCHARGE
OUR DUTIES AS LEGISLATORS IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER. IF WE WANT
TO LOOK OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THE
EYE AND SAY HEY. YOUR HEALTH
INSURANCE YOUR MEDICARE YOUR
MEDICARE ALL. YOUR BARGAIN FOR
HEALTH PLAN IN YOUR UNION THE
YOU PAID INTO FOR DECADES. WERE
TAKEN OUT OF WHY. WE'RE GIVING
YOU A TAX BILL AND WE'RE HANDING
YOU SOMETHING ELSE. GOOD LUCK
QUEUING UP TO GET YOUR SERVICE
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT A STATE THEY
CAN'T ISSUE DRIVERS LICENSES
PROPERLY THROUGH THE DMV IN
CANADA YOU. UNEMPLOYMENT CHECKS
PROPERLY THROUGH EDT BUT WE'RE
GONNA MAKE ALL OF THAT A STATE
AGENCY AND IT'S GOING TO CONTROL
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR HEALTH CARE
BEFORE WE CAN SAY HEY WE THAT'S
A GOOD IDEA WE WANT TO DO THAT.
WE AT LEAST NEED TO KNOW AND WE
HAVE A DUTY TO FIND OUT AND HAVE
THE L. A- FIND OUT HOW MUCH IT'S
GONNA COST. THAT'S A MINIMUM. I
FURTHER MOVED THAT THIS BILL BE
A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED BE HELD
IN THIS COMMITTEE UNTIL WE
RECEIVE. THE COST IMPACT REPORT
BACK FROM THE L. L. I THINK
THAT'S A VERY REASONABLE THING
TO DO I THINK. TAKING THAT
COURSE OF ACTION RATHER THAN A
SINGLE REFER TO HEALTH. SINGLE
REFERRAL TO HEALTH CARE. WILL
GIVE US THE INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED SO WE CAN LOOK OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE EYE. AND
TELL THEM THAT WE ARE BEING
RESPONSIBLE AS LEGISLATORS. SO
THAT IS MY MOTION. WHAT WERE.
LET ME THERE THERE IS A MOTION
ON THE TABLE- UNDER JOINT RULE
THIRTY SEVEN POINT ONE A LETTER
CAN BE SUBMITTED RULES
REQUESTING SUCH A STUDY. I
ACTUALLY THINK THE TIME WILL BE
RIPE. TO MAKE SUCH A REQUEST.
ONE OF THE ISSUES HERE IS THAT
UNDER LEGISLATION PASSED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. ARE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE CHAIR OUR
SUMMER HEALTH COMMITTEE CHAIR
HAVEN'T PARTICIPATED IN A
PROCESS FOR A HEALTHY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION WHICH HAS
BEEN DOING EXAMINATIONS OF THE
GENERAL TOPIC OF HEALTH CARE.
AND ARE GOING TO BE ISSUING A
FINAL REPORT DEALING WITH THEIR
ASSESSMENT OF FINANCING ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH BROAD AND HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. THE ISSUE I HAVE
IS IT IS THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
WHICH IN APRIL LAST YEAR-
REACHED OUT TO THE APPROPRIATE
STATE AGENCY OF PROGRAM REVIEW
TO GET A HIGH LEVEL INITIAL VIEW
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED. WHICH
WAS BECAUSE OF OUR CHAIR HE
SOUGHT THAT OUT. HE HAS BEEN
SERVING ON THIS PANEL WHICH IS
CLOSING IN ON AN UPDATED
EVALUATION. WHEN THAT REPORT
COMES OUT IT WILL ACTUALLY
POSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY. WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BILL OR ANY
SIMILAR BILL BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION'S FOCUS ON BROADER
ISSUES. WHAT IS KNOWN. AND WHAT
IS NOT KNOWN THAT WE MIGHT
ELUCIDATE BY FURTHER STUDY I
SORT OF THINK THE TIME TO ASK
THE L. A. O. TO WEIGH IN IS WHEN
WE'VE HAD AN EVALUATION OF
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT REMAIN
OPEN. AFTER THIS LONG PROCESS.
OF SO I ACTUALLY. PERSONALLY DO
NOT FAVOR REFERRAL OTHER
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME. UNDER
CALL O IT IS NOT UNUSUAL THAT
WE HAVE DONE SINGLE REFERRALS.
ON AND INDEED COMMITTEES THAT
HAVE HAD OTHER BILLS REFERRED TO
THEM HAVE SAID WE DON'T ACTUALLY
NEED TO SEE IT. ON. I ALSO THINK
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY.
THERE IS A ONE LEGISLATOR. WHO
HAS THE TIME AND THE INTEREST
AND HAS DISPLAYED THE TIME OF
THE AT FIRST AND THAT'S THE
CHAIR OF OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE
WHO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
PARTICIPATE WITH OTHER MEMBERS
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS IN
HISTORIC GROUND BREAKING
LEGISLATION BREAKING A LOGJAM ON
A VERY TOUGH ISSUE. BY
COLLABORATION. HE IS HEAVILY
INVESTED THIS TOPIC HE'S DONE
THE WORK HE'S IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS. WHATEVER HAPPENS
A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED THERE'S
AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
ASSEMBLY. TO DO ONGOING WORK
THIS WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE- WORK OF THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AFTER PROP ONE OF
THREE PASSED. A VERY COMPLICATED
MEASURE DEAL WITH AUTO INSURANCE
REGULATION AND PROPERTY CASUALLY
REGULATION THE STATE. AND AMELIE
UPON HIS PASSAGE. MAYBE IT WAS
THE HORSES OUT OF THE BARN. THE
ASSEMBLY CAREER FINANCE ACTUALLY
ORGANIZED COMMITTEES OF THE
WHOLE AND OTHER INDIFFERENT CDNS
. TO START MAKING SURE THAT THE
INSTITUTION OF THE ASSEMBLY. WAS
FULLY GROUNDED ALL THE
RAMIFICATIONS AT PROPOSAL. I
THINK AS A PRACTICAL MATTER IF
WE DO NOT MOVE THE BILL FORWARD
THE BILL WILL SIT IN THE SENATE
TILL THEY GET TO ASSEMBLY BILLS
LATER IN THE YEAR. AND WE'LL OF
LOST FIVE MONTHS. FOR A
PRODUCTIVE EXAMINATION OF THE
ISSUES AROUND THIS TOPIC. AND OF
. SINCE MY PERSONAL HISTORY ON
THIS TOPIC GOES BACK TO NINETEEN
NINETY IN WASHINGTON DC WEISBERG
TWO DAYS WITH A GUY NAMED ALLEN
AND TOLD THAT OF STANFORD- WHO
IS INTERESTED IN COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACES. MANAGED
COMPETITION HEALTHCARE LONG
BEFORE THE CLINTON EFFORT. I
ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THERE'S AMPLE
BASIS FOR OUR- HEALTH COMMITTED
TO A GOOD AND THOROUGH JOB AND
USE THE TIME PRODUCTIVELY. IT
POINT CLARIFICATION IF I CAN
JUST PICTURE I BELIEVE THAT.
JOINT RULE THIRTY SEVEN POINT
ONE. BY ITS PLAIN TERMS SAYS ANY
MEMBER CAN MAKE UP THIS MOTION
AND THE RECOMMENDATION SHALL BE
HEARD AND VOTED ON BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE IT'S A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION FOR THE PRAYER PRIOR
MOTION THAT WAS MADE TO REFER
AT. AND I THINK. I'D LIKE A VOTE
ON. YEAH IT'S NOT A- IT IS NOT A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION THERE'S
NOTHING THAT THREE SEVEN ONE
THAT ACTUALLY SPEAKS TO THE
ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY COMMITTEE
IT IS A IS A ROUTE TO GET-
EXAMINATION OF SUBSTANCE DONE- I
FEEL THAT THE PROPER ROUTE IS A
LETTER PROPOSING THAT AND I
ACTUALLY TAKE IT AS A LETTER
THAT IS SPECIFIC AS TO WHAT WE
ARE ASKING THE L. A. O. TO DO-
THAT ADDRESSES. KNOWN UNKNOWNS
WITH RESPECT TO THIS. LARGE
TOPIC- RESTAURANTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR- IN
LINE A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION
ON ON THIS BILL MY QUESTION IS-
REVOLVE AROUND THE REVENUE-
ASPECT OF THIS BILL I KNOW
THERE'S INTENT IN THE LANGUAGE
THAT SAYS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FORWARD ON
IDENTIFYING THE REVENUE ASPECT
OF IT SO IF I COULD GET SOME
CLARITY AS FAR AS- I KNOW IT'S
REFERRED TO HEALTH WHICH IS
HEALTH CARE FOR THOSE IN OUR IN
OUR STATE BUT THE REVENUE
ALLOCATION PLAN THE REVENUE PLAN
THAT'S IN HERE THAT'S- TALKED
ABOUT THROUGHOUT THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- WHY WHY AREN'T WE
SENDING THAT TO- TAX AND REV
ALSO AT THIS TIME. IS THERE-
SOME INFORMATION THAT WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT THAT'S COMING- AS FAR
TO ADDRESS THAT PART OF IT. A
THE FUNDING STRUCTURE IS. AT A
HIGH LEVEL WELL UNDERSTOOD
INVOLVES A NEED FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS ON
THERE ARE PROVISIONS AND A
CONSCIOUS AMOUNT OF THIS
AFFECTED BEEN ADOPTED. SO I
ANTICIPATE THAT AS EXAMINATION
OF THAT ACA PROCEEDS- LIGHT WILL
BE SHED ON ALL THESE ISSUES I
THINK ARE IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE ARE THE LEGISLATURE-
MISTER WOODS SERVES ON THIS
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA GROUP. THE
AUTHOR OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
WROTE TO SECRETARY GALLEY.
ASKING FOR THEIR INPUT. ON THE
FINANCING AND IN A RATHER LONG
LETTER BASICALLY WAS TOLD. WHERE
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH WE'RE NOT
GOING TO OFFER COMMENTARY ON
YOUR BILL AT THIS TIME. THIS IS
A. UNDERMINES THE ABILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENGAGE IN FACTUAL
INQUIRY- I DO BELIEVE AGAIN THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO ISSUE A REPORT
I THINK THAT IS A RIPE SUBJECT
FOR THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO
BRING TO THE FULL BODY TO WALK
TO THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT IT
WILL BUILD UPON THE STUDY THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ALREADY
INITIATED- IN APRIL OF LAST YEAR
IT WILL IDENTIFY USES WE NEED
FURTHER EXAMINATION AND THAT
WILL GIVE US A POWERFUL LANDS TO
EVALUATE. CONSCIOUS AMOUNT
BEFORE COULD YOU MISTER WOOD
MISTER FLORA. YEAH JUST A FOLLOW
UP MITCHELL CHAIR- JUST TO BE
CLEAR THAT. I HEARD THAT THERE
IS GOING TO BE AN ACA THAT WOULD
BE THE A MECHANISM TO- HAVE THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THE REVENUE
STREAM OF THIS THIS PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF. HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL. YES THAT IS CORRECT THANK
YOU MISTER CHIP. IT WAS
INTRODUCED YESTERDAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND TO MY CALL
ALMOST QUESTION ABOUT THE FUND
SOURCE WHICH ACTUALLY WHAT I
WANT TO TALK. ABOUT TO. FOR JUST
A BRIEF MOMENT- IN THAT ACA. IT
EXPLICITLY STATES THAT THIS MAY
WOULDN'T AN EXCISE TAX. THE
PAYROLL. PERSONAL IN HEALTHCARE
TAX. AND ONE OF THE PARTS OF IN
MIND. IS THAT THE MEASURE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE LEGISLATURE PART
AND ECONOMIC ANALYSIS DETERMINED
IN SUFFICIENT AMOUNTS TO FUND
THESE PURPOSES TO INCREASE ANY.
OR ALL TAXES. BY STATUTE PASSED
WITH A SIMPLE MAJORITY. WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS. THE ROUGH COSTS
THAT IMPRINT IS ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S THE NUMBER THAT WE'RE
HERE THAT'S WHAT THESE TAXES-
TRIED TO WERE ALREADY ADMITTED
IN THIS THAT WE DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE ENOUGH MONEY. SO
GOING TO HAVE TO COME BACK AND
RAISE TAXES AGAIN. ONCE AGAIN
BREAKING FROM THE PRACTICE THAT
THAT TWO THIRDS VOTE. IF THIS
GOES THROUGH IF THIS ACA. DOES
NOT GET FIXED THIS FUNDING
SOURCE DOES NOT GET SHAKEN OUT
PROPERLY. WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
SIMPLE MAJORITY. WHO HAS THE
ABILITY TO RAISE TAXES ON EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR LIVES. WITH A
SIMPLE MAJORITY VOTE. I THINK
THAT IS DEVASTATING. I THINK
THAT IS INCREDIBLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AND I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD TAKE
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS. WE'RE NOT
JUST ASKING A TAX ON THE RICH.
MIKE IN THE IN THE LANGUAGE THAT
TALKS ABOUT ANYBODY MAKING OVER
FORTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS. IS
GONNA GET A TAX. IT GOES UP FROM
THERE. THAT IS LOW INCOME MIDDLE
INCOME FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN WITH THEIR LABOR GROUPS
AND HAVE HEALTH CARE PLANS. WE
THROW IT OUT. IT WAS PUT
SOMETHING NEW IN THEIR PLACE.
COLLEAGUES ARM. OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS BROKEN WE ALL THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED. BUT TO JAM OF THIS DOWN
THIS BODIES GROW. WITH VERY
LITTLE. INPUT AND THE FACT THAT
THERE'S ALREADY A CA IMPRINT BUT
WE'RE STILL ONLY TALKING ABOUT
SINGLE REFERRED TO UNDERSTAND
CODE I GET ALL OF THAT. BUT WE
HAVE THE LARGEST TAX IN TH
COUNTRY'S HISTORY. STARING US IN
THE FACE. AND WE'RE NOT JUST IN
A DRIVEN TAX. THANK YOU MISTER
FOR ARM. I GUESS THE ISSUE I
WOULD SAY. OUR. THE ONLY BODY.
THAT HAS CONSTITUTIONAL STANDING
REALLY TO GRAPPLE WITH ISSUES OF
THIS CHARACTER IS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY. I AM STRONGLY IN FAVOR. OF
KEEPING THIS CONVERSATION
ANALYSTS SAY BODY. IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO LET THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH RUN A CONVERSATION. AT
THE END WHEN A LAWMAKER ASKED
FOR ADVICE THEY SAY WE CAN'T
GIVE IT TO YOU. WE HAVEN'T GOT A
SIGN OFF FROM THE GOVERNOR. THAT
IS AN AFFRONT TO THE DIGNITY OF
THIS INSTITUTION. WE HAVE A
CHAIRMAN. WHO HAS A RECORD OF A
COMFY MIGHTY THINGS TO A BI
PARTISAN EFFORT THAT IS FACT
BASED ON SPEAKING OUT MEDICAL
MARIJUANA MR LACKEY MR BONTA
MYSELF BECAUSE A REGISTERED
SAWYER REQUIREMENTS FOR LARA. WE
HAVE SIX MONTHS I THINK BEFORE
THE SENATE REALLY ENGAGES ON
THIS BILL. SO I FEEL IT IS TIME
. FOR US TO PULL THIS ISSUE INTO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHICH TO
ME IS THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. IT'S
THE VENUE THEY CAN PULL IN
WHOEVER THEY WANT AS A PART OF
JOINT HEARING. BUT I THINK THERE
IS THERE IS A MEMBER IN THIS
BODY. WHO IS INVESTED IN THE
SUBJECT. AND BRING SOME STATURE
AND SOME HISTORY ESOL I'M JUST
SAYING. YOU KNOW IT'S I GOT UP
THIS MORNING I DECIDED. IT'S
SORT OF LIKE WERE. NOT RECOGNIZE
OUR OWN AUTHORITY. THAT'S
ABNEGATION SO I WENT LOOKING FOR
MY OXFORD DICTIONARY AND LOOKED
UP ABNEGATION TURNED AWAY FROM
ONE'S OWN AUTHORITY AND I GOT
QUITE A WAKE UP CALL READING
THAT DICTIONARY DEFINITION
AGGREGATION THE ACT OF
ANNOUNCING A REJECTED SOMETHING
. ABROGATION OF POLITICAL LAW
MAKING POWER IT SAYS IN THE
OXFORD DICTIONARY. I AM NOT A
FAN OF ABROGATION OF POLITICAL
LEGISLATIVE LAWMAKING POWER.
THIS IS THE PLACE WHERE IT
SHOULD BE DONE. I GRANT YOU
YEAH- CUSTOMER WOULD EVENTUALLY
HAVE TO BE PASSED BY THE VOTERS
. IT'S NOT A SLAM DUNK BY ANY
MEANS IT DOESN'T FEEL TO ME LIKE
ACTUALLY THE SMALLER PROP WILL
TREAT OUR PROP THIRTEEN TYPE OF
ISSUE. BUT THIS IS THE VENUE
WHERE WE ARE TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS. IT MAY BE THAT
WE'RE OUT OF PRACTICE. AND I
WOULD SAY UNDER TERM LIMITS AT A
CERTAIN THE CASE. BUT THIS IS
JANUARY. SIX I PREFER TO BET ON
THE INSTITUTION. AND POLAR
CONVERSATION INTO OUR CLOSETS
AND OUR PUBLIC HEARING ROOMS.
MISTER I JUST WANNA BE PERFECTLY
CLEAR MY MOTION OR JOINT RULE
THIRTY SEVEN POINT ONE- THAT AM
I GOING TO GET A VOTE ON IT ONE
AND TWO I WANNA BE PERFECTLY
CLEAR THAT PROVIDES THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
PART OF THIS INSTITUTION. DO THE
STUDY NOT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YES I THAT IS THAT IS
ALL THAT I WAS GOING. YEAH I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU SUBMIT THAT TO
BE A LETTER BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE
TO WORK ON. THAT WITH THE
CHAIRMAN. I ACTUALLY FEEL
BECAUSE IT'S OUR OWN ENTITY WE
ARE GOING TO WE HAVE THE PRODUCT
OF THE EARLY STUDY THAT THE
CHAIRMAN SECURED. ON THIS BILL.
WE HAVE THE SOON TO BE RELEASED
OVERVIEW OF FINANCING ISSUES OF
WHICH SHE HAS BEEN A PARTNER IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS HE HAS
FOLLOWED THEM. WITH HIS STAFF.
WE'RE GONNA FIGURE OUT VERY
QUICKLY WHERE DO PUSH POINTS TO
BE WORK CRITICAL ISSUES. YOU
KNOW THIS COULD BE LIKE LONG
TERM CARE. SET UP A SYSTEM
PROVIDE BENEFITS AND WHAT
HAPPENED PEOPLE LIVE LONGER AND
COST ROSE. THERE ARE QUESTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS THAT NEED
TO BE UNDERSTOOD. AND I FEEL
THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE A
PRODUCTIVE OPPORTUNITY. TO GO TO
THE ALEJO. BUT I FEEL IT SHOULD
BE. TARGETED FOR THOSE KNOWN
UNKNOWNS WE CAN IDENTIFY- SO
THAT WE ACTUALLY DEVELOPER
CORPUS OF INFORMATION TO SUPPORT
THE EIGHTY MEMBERS OF THIS BODY
THEIR DELIBERATIONS AND- I SAN
BEDA LEISURE PROCESS I'M ALSO
BETTING ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
BUT SO I WOULD REQUEST ACTUALLY
THAT- I WOULD HAVE DECLINED TO
TAKE UP THAT. MOTION BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IT'S PREMATURE BUT I
WOULD REQUEST THAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE FORM OF A LETTER AND- I WILL
INTEND TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR ON
HOW TO TARGET SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. MR WHAT. ON AGAIN OFF
AGAIN WHETHER I WANTED TO SPEAK
ON THIS BUT I WANT TO SPEAK TO
ONE. PIECE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND A BUNCH I DO
HAVE. INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF. AND
THAT IS THE HEALTH FOR ALL
COMMISSION. THE HELP BROUGHT
COMMISSION EXIST BECAUSE OF
LEGISLATION I DID AFTER- SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO- WAS NOT REFERRED.
THAT WAS OUR WORK GOVERNOR BROWN
AGREED THAT WE SHOULD STUDY THIS
ANY FUNDED IT IN A BUDGET. SO
THAT COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
COMMISSION HAS BEEN MEETING- FOR
MONTHS NOW. AND I WANT TO WHAT
SHOULD UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE BODY
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT ADDRESS HOW
TO FIND A. B. FOURTEEN HUNDRED.
IT DOES NOT WHAT IT DOES DO IS
IT LOOKS AT ALL OF THE ISSUES.
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED TO
FINANCE TO CREATE A PUBLICLY OR
A UNIFIED PUBLICLY FINANCED
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM OF WHICH
THERE ARE MANY. SO WHEN IT'S THE
WHEN THE REPORT IS RELEASED. IT
MIGHT PRODUCE THE ROAD MAP TO
HOW TO FUND THIS PROGRAM. BUT IT
ALSO WILL LAY OUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE GOING
FORWARD. AND I AM NOT A VOTING
MEMBER I'M AN EX OFFICIO MEMBER-
AND I'M THANKFUL- TO THIS BODY
AND OUR LEADER- TO HELP TO GET
ME ON TO THAT COMMISSION BECAUSE
I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ON THIS
COMMISSION WERE IT NOT FOR THE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS HOUSE NOR
WOULD SENATOR PAT. SO WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BE THERE AND
PROVIDE INPUT AND LISTEN TO ALL
OF THE DELIBERATIONS GOING
FORWARD. AND SO. I'VE BEEN A
PART OF THIS YEAH I KNOW WHAT'S
COMING AND- AND I KNOW WHAT IT
WILL OFFER AND I KNOW WHAT IT
WON'T OFFER BUT I WANT TO BE
CLEAR. THAT ABOUT SOME OF THAT
AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK WITH ANY
ABOUT THAT GOING FORWARD OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR WOULD. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. OF MY SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I BONTA. BONTA AYE CARILLO
CARILLO HI FLORA FLORA NO
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS. MATHIS NO
RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO RUBIO NOT
VOTING STONE STONE I WOULD I
WOULD HI MOTION PASSES THE
MOTION PASSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JUST RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.